j'ai demandé au chroniqueur de nous
raconter des anecdotes personnelles sur
l'infidélité elles vont apparaître dans
l'écran d'ailleurs à toi de découvrir
quelques chroniqueurs a eu cette
anecdote j'ai servi d'alibi à une
personne un fidèle pendant des années je
sais pas moi je connais pas les réponses
un mois moi si j'étais toi moi je moi je
sais pas je le sens j'irai sur une fille
ça va moi aussi moi je sens bien
beinheim eh bien non ah oui j'avais une
hésitation avec qui a gardé à la gueule
ah non non elle elle c'est elle qui a dû
être infidèle moi j'ai un peu sur bnl à
cela dit ouais mais on peut pas tout
mathieu ccsl moi je me servira bien de
mathieu par exemple atteint amour et
mathieu je sens qu'on peut lui faire
contre leurs bastions le sait vous alors
absolument pas non c'est vrai qu'on peut
me faire confiance et qui tiendra ses
buts à 1 alors que sa mère en fait au
départ je ne savais pas que j'étais la
libye ah ouais c'est quand le copain
appelé à la maison que j'ai compris que
j'étais à ma libye et qu'il fallait que
trop vite une solution telle que l'a
prouvé et bas s'y trouvaient bah oui ben
en fait j'ai dit que j'ai dit qu'elle
s'était qu'elle s'était blessée et qu'on
était en route pour nom mais si fusion
c'est normal et qui trouve un truc qu'on
était en route pour la pharmacie et
qu'elle m'attendait en bail que moi je
préfère le cheval sur trois ferme et la
maison et qu'elle est égale attendait un
problème c'est qu'après fall a blessé
vraiment
au lieu qu'elle était en bas et ouais
voilà ai jamais cru ça ne valait rien
moi aussi je savais pas et quand a
commencé quand elle le compagnon qui
appelle et que c'est toi ton ami bateau
est entre amis fans en deux jours j'ai
fait référence au fait que les amis une
fois que c'est fait main après t2t prise
en main
bah oui bah oui bon de toute façon elle
a quitté la paix la personne en question
qui me rappelle que d'autres où la
ressource le graff
alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres je
vous le dis moi sur vigier j'ai attribué
des jours de la semaine à deux personnes
différentes
ça veut dire qu'on travaille moi je
réponds agathe aujourd'hui la partagent
la semaine avec 2,9 alors aux voitures
qui suit au filet il a cassé à chaque
fois ben non non non non non je n'en
bouge à maman s'il n'y a pas assez de
jours
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux jours de la semaine à deux
personnes différentes
ça sent bien ça sent bien j'en prends
même pas la question jean michel noir
s'évanouit dans ces combats de la cale
d'intelligent et infidèle donc y en a
pas cinquante autour de la table 1 1 à
tisser ou naulleau ou agathe ou de leur
boîte est intelligent sa régate à l'est
à égalité par agathe et vos amis c'est
moi à les mecs
salut c'est moi c'était face à un
dilemme j'ai trouvé une solution on
était en cm1 et raphaël
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais bah oui mais moi c'est mince
avance de la semaine dernière mon patron
je ne suis pas un fidèle
voilà on va très bien voilà alors d'une
crise avait passé le pas que j'ai vu
cinq niveaux voilà donc c'était ocm
samassa par la prescription agathe c'est
bon au bout on vous pardonne pas comment
souvient de sang se passe comme si
c'était tout va bien la saison on avait
fait des croix sur les sur les agendas
et donc c'est ouf stg le roulage de
pelle ont roulé pas des ballons se
tenait la main on se donnait des robes à
west et quikcast annexes et la finance
est manquant j'ai passé 48 heures seul
dans un hôtel pour couvrir une
infidélité à 40 ça c'est un truc de
losers sa s'est réuni
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non moi je
penserait plutôt voilà non pas bon et
bien non c'est nous pas moi c'est qui
qui voit là c'est vraiment fini c'est un
truc de loser c'est moi il ya un pote à
moi qui étais avec une nana à vierzon et
elle appelle la nana l'appel à lui dit
je débarque chez toi danton pavillon je
foute de bordeaux avec tes gosses et
toute la famille il m'appelle et me dit
faut absolument que tu viens avec moi
pour me couvrir faut qu'on se barre en
tournoi de foot à vierzon tout de suite
parce que l'autre avoir appliqué sur
paris je vais me faire démonter je dit
vas-y on y va on vend tournoi on arrive
là bas et du coup pendant 48 heures de
temps qui désamorce et qui calme l'autre
parce qu'il fallait la calmer a voulu à
tout prix revenir sur paris
le temps qu'ils calment l'otan a pris
deux chambres d'hôtel j'étais à côté au
cas où sa femme à la plèbe un juteux le
pass je vais dans la chambre à côté
chauffeur sur téléphones android puis
j'ai passé 48 heures à me faire chier à
l'hôtel quoi alors je vous lis on va
mettre tout de suite ont plein de reno
mais ça veut dire que c'est un super
pote haut et ça il faut le faire c'est
un numéro azur pour les personnes que le
compris cette année
[Applaudissements]
mais je faisais
la muraille et hamouma partenaires une
photo de moi en train de faire l'amour
avec quelqu'un d'autre part dont il a
envoyé par erreur à son ou sa partenaire
une photo de lui ou d'elle en train de
faire l'amour et celles qui ont même été
l'horreur c'est plutôt facile de zabel
c'est énorme
ces gens me donnent alors c'est qu'il ya
trop peu de gens
philippe sait pas s'il bat je pense que
c'est mathieu mathieu il faut me lâcher
maintenant beaucoup moi aussi c'est pour
ça je vais c'est pas moi c'est qu'il est
plus mal
j'ai honte pas ma vie c'est terrible et
tout ce qui s'en veut toujours faire le
malin banon mais j'étais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien photographier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
oui alors on veut garder des souvenirs
ce que je m'attache pour ce faire vous
méprenez souple rarement des souvenirs
de deux monuments rêve à savoir et bien
enfin bon je prends une photo d'un acte
sexuel avec une personne que j'aimais
beaucoup mais qui n'était pas ma
partenaire officiel mais je vois la
photo est un pote qui l'a qui fait aussi
m'a dit [ __ ] si tu arrives à la
séduire sur mineur séduiront te taquiner
mais comment on fait pour prendre une
photo pendant l'essai sa gnac une
position pas je suis expliquée n'ont pu
déjà formulé donc là donc du coup je
fais une photo et je l'envoie se dit
potes ce qui m'avait dit prouve moi tu
sais que c'est vrai avec tulle asséné
des coups genre la photo est comme moi
je pense est forcément pas culpabilité à
ma partenaire officiel je cherche son
numéro et un concert manches 6 4 et
numéro deux mains même appartement
la faute aux partis et je tape on n'a
pas le même alors salorges et techniques
pour ça tout de suite faut mettre sur
mode avion non même quand tu l'as lu
c'est fini mode avion sa part aprilia
moi ça va t'arriver ça c'est pour ta va
pas du tout avec une fille mais ça m'est
arrivé un jour réaliser un bon moment
vas-y bah oui ok un film pour luc besson
ouais et le soir on a varié et d'eau qui
c'est lui qui produisait cette infime
qu'il avait écrit que je réalisais et le
soir on n'est pas d'accord sur le
casting et on s'engueule un peu comme
humble par texto est une libre à l'aiea
demain à demain à 7h30 de ma femme
m'appelle je réponds et besson me disent
que t'es réveillé
donc j oui et ça reprend la discussion
et ma femme envoie est ce que toi t'es
réveillé giresse a fait une demi heure
je me prends la tête avec l'autre pète
couilles de besson non les gens voient
vite
[ __ ] on va prendre des mois on va dire
voyez un sms comme ça aussi un
chroniqueur de laurent ruquier
non je cherchais son numéro et il dit
ouais il yal'autre condamne una qui
cherchent de nouveaux ancrages lui donne
et mes envois je l'appelle j'ai dit
alors t'es trompé non mais c'est pas du
tout ce que tu as lors il est encore
vivant aujourd'hui vous allez les dépôts
dans le paf j'ai dû occuper la maîtresse
d'un ami pendant qu'il était avec sa
femme sa commence a occupé la presse pas
compris que la messe j'ai dû occuper
donc la maîtresse d'un ami pendant
quitté que sa femme
ça devrait être le contraire elle occupe
et la femme mais il va nous expliquer ce
qui s'est passé c'est naulleau ça c'est
compliqué c'est naulleau chez moi
quelqu'un voici un manille à un ami très
proche qui avait donné rendez vous en
même temps à sa femme et à sa maîtresse
chez lui non il me dit ça va jouer là
dix minutes c'est vrai tu emmènes la
maîtresse ou tu veux je suis dit j'ai
pas tellement envie de sortir ce soir
une bille si tu as envie de sortir
je te prête ma bagnole je te cite 200
balles des gages à l'ailé rôle du passé
la fille je ne la connaissais pas je
l'avais jamais vu de ma vie en est il a
réussi à la convaincre de passer la
soirée au restaurant avec maintenant
c'est ouf elle ensuite j'ai couché avec
pas nous en servir
allons bon
j'ai juste à gagner 200 bêtes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
besoin c'est vous à votre à milan et ce
serait magnifique naulleau à nous taper
show s'en méfier je suis là c'est tout
ce chemin on regarde on a relevé de
compte
ah ça c'est quelqu'un qui enquêtent
c'est bien sinon c'est une fille ça
c'est une fille c'est isabelle et mes
propos l'amarrage enquête pas je m'en
fous c'est quoi ça sert c'est toi quoi
bah oui parce que ma femme était partie
soit disant pour un tournage j'avais un
gros doute sur le look c'est un tournage
voilà tournage évidemment réduit les
produits est en fait j'étais sûr qu'il
n'était pas à l'endroit où des qualités
et donc j'ai appelé évidemment la carte
mu il dit moi quelles sont les dépenses
faites et à quel endroit et j'ai su
qu'elle était effectivement annecy non
pas aller on en est là franchement si
dans la fidélité déjà surprenante mais
ce qui est encore plus surprenant c'est
qu'il regarde de relevés de compte c'est
ça nous avons été fait avec la peau
québec jusqu'à des buffalos des foulures
et mon conjoint a cru que j'étais
infidèle à cause de la télé c'est ça
c'est le séjour de ses finances
non non merci on a su revenir et isabel
allende philippe séguin et oui c'est moi
c'est vous qui s'est passé je partais
c'était en 82 du parfait en 9 82 après
jésus-christ
jusqu'à prévisible c'est parti en
reportage en normandie avec des copains
il y avait dans le lot un très beau
garçon qui est terré que tu travailles à
jouer qui révèle que j'ai une maison
avec lui je quitte mon mari et on s'est
retrouvé en normandie et porter la
poisse ce garçon était formidable il
portait la poisse
il ya une congère de neige qui se
forment et on se retrouve la seule
bagnole qui se retrouvent dans la
congère de neige c'est la nôtre avec le
très beau garçon et moi jy caméras de
france 3 normandie arrive et elle fume
et la présentatrice et moi je le savais
pas annonce qu' on vient de trouver un
couple à 17 reprises du concept
[Rires]
pardon
[Applaudissements]
oui
des missions s'émeut deux heures de
raconter des merdes sur la langue
[Applaudissements]
mon compagnon à ya des gens qu'on est
devant marie maintenant ta femme et
bigame savais pas ça voilà mon mari à 10
mais c'est confiance à l'échéance ou
justin schack à quelle heure vous avez
décroché à congères je suis resté caché
toute une journée dans un parking pour
surprendre mon conjoint
bon ça c'est une fille ça c'est le genre
de ealing c'est que les gens et les
collégiens faits dégueulasses et mathieu
et merde philippe val et hees était de
la sortie encore vous avez donc émis les
bras sur un thème bien oui c'est moi
mais je suis resté sur l enquête l avoue
j'avoue c'est moi à l e j'étais plus
jeune mais la géolocalisation existait
déjà
bon s'il ya deux ans on a compris le
bois l'enfant c'était après longtemps et
j'avais une copine qui m'avait aidé à
mettre un mouchard dans mon portable
pour localiser mon mec
bah oui bah quand faut le faire pour le
faire et à un moment donné je lui ai dit
bah je vais dormir chez une copine
tranquille il m'a dit oui je reste à la
maison avec des potes et tout donc je me
suis pas très bien qui me dit ça parce
que je savais qu'il resterait pas du
tout là et j'ai passé ma soirée à un
moment donné je me suis dit bon on va zy
3 4h du mat je vais de localiser lâché
avec ma copine est fou c'est le look
attention aux glissades bien non au
final j'étais dans 91 chez moi et je me
suis retrouvé dans paris à l'attendre
dans un parking souterrain et à le
chauffer en bas de la boîte et veut dire
bah elle le sait moins c est le seul
huawei et ses morts mais ses sorties il
était sorti pour moi ça veut dire la
même chose
j'avoue des fois il est juste sorti en
voit même pierre d'assise et peut-être
plusieurs 9
elle est jalouse elle est jalouse mais
je vous dis alors oui c'était une belle
histoire
bon ben alors annoncé que ces deux
sétois mathieu j'ai eu une relation avec
la femme d'un mec pour lequel ma petite
amie m'a quittée après ce que la cup
mathieu big ben oui oui c'est ça alors
en fait en fait ma petite amie de
l'époque était parti avec un petit à
l'époque était parti avec avec un mec
et puis la femme du mec débarque chez
moi en me disant vous savez que mon mari
est parti avec boîte femme marie alors
j'ai dit je vais me venger
alors j'ai dit vous savez moi je on peut
faire un truc ouais on va coucher
ensemble et puis comme ça vous allez lui
faire savoir et là vous êtes vraiment
venger mais lui et lui les amis un bazar
[Rires]
d'un côté elle voulait recommencer le
lendemain mais moi comme je voulais
reprendre la bizarrerie
donc oui mais alors ça à 1000 vous étiez
en pantalon moulant quand elle est
arrivée j'avais toujours la canette dans
le besoin
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je peux je peux dire que
c'est mathieu bois alors mathieu je suis
sorti et que jumeaux de mon partenaire
classique
ouais bah on s'est quand même mais
attention qu'igor et grichka c'est de là
qu'est partie la fameuse morte au nahd
voilà tu parles tu sais que le sens du
rythme amis à la télé c'est que voulant
rendre service sur instagram à des fans
qui m'écrivent y en a un très beau qui
m'écrit un jour je le rencontre on prend
un verre parce que je voulais savoir ce
qu'ils devenaient il est très beau il a
un frère jumeau je l'ignorais on couche
ensemble ouais c'est super une bombe
trois jours après me revoir on re couche
ensemble d'accords est bon en fait il
s'est fait un petit pari entre les deux
petits coquinous à la beckett 2 pouvait
taper le même et en fait quand je
retouche est le deuxième c'était le
frère non mais c'est fou les jours tant
que je n'ai pas vu et pourtant
normalement mais bon ya pas de ckx
pareil on a un bon rythme ralenti
[Rires]
attention dos d'âne
[Applaudissements]
là on est bien meilleur moteur on peut
quand même s'arrêter deux minutes sur la
phrase de conclusion oui y'a pas de sexe
pas la raison c'est vrai on aime ça
son bâtiment mais 10 différents autant
chez les 10 je te retrouve lady
parthenay bien sûr la société lieu non
loin des 3 mais mieux vaut mieux rire
sans avoir vu je vous jure c'est vrai
sans avoir un jour tu prends de
n'importe qui veut mais si oui au hasard
tu le mets je te dis qu'il serait
d'accord va très bien santini tout lunel
dans la fiche affiche de la châtoire sur
ce qu'on appelle à houston oui bon ça va
être très bref à propos de deux frères
jumeaux moi c'est ma meilleure amie car
il n'y a pas longtemps que son père qui
avait un frère jumeau en fait que son
père se sont donc non d'aller en ville
il a demandé à son frère de prendre sa
place et conjugale et serrait son frère
est mon cas et c'est un truc de ouf
moi ma mère elle vient d'apprendre que
mon père et son frère